before we get started would you like
some fun dragon facts for kids
yes i would
so a dragon has zero to four legs
claws scales and possibly spikes and it
may also have wings sometimes they have
horns and hair a dragon can usually fly
some dragons live in caves and dragons
hoard precious metals and jewels
[Music]
are you
ready to talk about dragons
i am
okay in this game the player or players
it's the two of us we're in a land full
of dragons the dragons all live in caves
with their large piles of collected
treasure some dragons are friendly and
share their treasure
other dragons are hungry and eat anyone
who enters their cave the players
approach two caves one with a friendly
dragon and the other with a hungry
dragon
but we don't know which dragon is in
which cave and we have to choose between
the two so we're gonna take all of this
and put it into
a shiny app
all right
let's speak
[Music]
if we think about this like in terms of
running an r script
this wouldn't be the most
complex thing like if i was just gonna
do
dragonrealm.r
right this could this is this is almost
oh gosh this is what like an if-else
statement
right
yeah with it with a menu that you can
ask the user for for input
good but there's like
kind of like three big uis that we need
to look at
right
the intro ui
like and choose choose a cave
there would be like
then the logic that we check
uh and then ask to play again
i don't know they
can appear not appear if i was to make a
game
the way that i start a shiny app
i haven't programmed a shiny app in a
really long time
it's been a month so i do shiny up and
then i shift tab and that my friends is
the shortcut that i have to share with
you how how do we go about this barrett
like i am very inclined
to design a beautiful ui first and i
know that that is
like what we saw with winston
and wordle with nick and winston like
should we always be designing the logic
of our app first or should we make it
beautiful first
i am a fan of logic you were so how do
how do we start
this
um i really like that flow chart um
so
let's i think we can turn that into like
some comments here and then we can try
to fill in
some functions
okay
this is our flow chart and so step one
is we start and i'm gonna just be going
back and forth
between screens so then
introductory text
and then a player chooses a cave
all right and then it we check
we check for
a hungry dragon
or a friendly dragon i feel like this is
a false dichotomy
like you can be hungry i mean can you be
hungry and friendly though maybe not
no it's usually just hangry
so you
should bring them us snickers
ah all right and then we ask to play
again
and then we end i mean well yeah i mean
i guess if you play again you could like
go through as many times as you want but
ultimately the game like if you say no
then it's an end
yeah we'll we'll do a
line after 20 and say
if yes go to start
so where can we
do logic that has nothing to do with
shiny
at all
um
so
logic that has nothing to do with shiny
i guess what i'm thinking is
introductory text maybe
so this is an output
we do a text output
yeah that works for me just gonna copy
paste this introductory text let's
actually do one more thing above line
five and add
i just default h1s
uh and let's just say h1 intro
like what stage are we at in this ui
okay so
[Music]
we'll do a comma because we're working
with shiny
and i am going to set this up to run in
my viewer pane
and the text output uh
doesn't need to be as shiny um the text
output is expecting
so this is more like a paragraph so just
a p tag
look at that
boom
done
okay
is there anything else let's see is
there anything else we can do
that would not be
shiny related um i don't think so
because any other text is now
buried
behind decisions
uh true but we can also just kind of put
everything in one big layout in the
beginning and we just you know will only
update certain parts of the ui
so we could ask them the question then
for
which cave do you want to do and maybe
add in two buttons
okay anything
so we could do um
let's actually let's do this which would
you like to enter
[Music]
and put that in there
so which cable you go into one or two
and then we want two buttons so we could
do action button
uh input id and this will be
we can call it
k1
[Music]
yeah we can do the label of
cave one
please
i miss shinee
okay so this should give us
oh and they're right next to each other
too
i don't know why i expected them to
stack but perfect
from surprises
so let's try to separate the intro in
the question so let's add another h1
above line 10.
great and uh
probably because we're going from the
intro to the question we'll need like a
continue button
i like that so you're saying here we'll
do
action button
uh
id equals
and we'll do
uh maybe like an intro continue because
it seems to be lots of
transitions
that's a good point
oh yeah under sorry
all right so then there's i would say
what an answer like
a response
all right dramatic it's very dramatic um
so this would be
this would be a text output of some kind
right because
something's happening
um but would we do it as a key for now
just as like yeah we could have wind
text and lose text yeah
when text
use text
okay
and then if we look at our flow charts
so that's this and then we ask if they
want to play again
play again
and then that would
be guess another button
or two
yes extra button input id
equals
again
and then we would do one that is
end game
we can just say no thank you
all right
and we'll switch the input ids to be
underscores
just because subsetting an r doesn't
like
minus signs because it's actually
minus so what i feel like is there's a
couple of directions we can go
one is
we know when we play this game we're not
going to have the whole thing just laid
out right we're going to see an intro
and then the button is going to take us
to
this and then right so there's different
kind of ui
pieces that show or like we break this
ui up into pages or fancy programming
term
so that's one direction to go another
would be
the logic of like oh i click cave one
and then i see this consequence text
let's do uh
some of the logic for
hooking up the buttons because we can
see everything right here and that way
debugging is a lot faster because we
don't need to go through four screens to
see if we want to play again and then we
can just print a message
just to know that it's hooked up but it
doesn't actually have to do anything
we've got intro to intro underscore
continue as our action button in our ui
so now we're going to come all the way
down to our server
and
what do i hook up oh my gosh my brain is
blank
so we want side effects only and you
never do it
when the button is pressed
so observe event
yes
that was like a rough moment
my brain just forgot everything okay so
it wants the event expression
um
so with is that just input
intro to intro underscore continue
uh yes okay spelling on input
thank you
pair programming
all right and we always add comma curly
brackets because it's just always an
expression
okay so observe event input input intro
continue and then you said something
really important that i
will uh do comma curly brackets because
the action that we'll take should be a
bigger expression so we want to make
sure we have the curly brackets
and so since we're just hooking it up
would we just do like is it print or is
it message
i like message okay um
message
uh
continue button was pressed or something
okay
so if we just run this
what should happen is when i click the
continue button
we get our message in our console
perfect so then we just kind of continue
that
for cave one cave two play again and no
thank you
correct
[Music]
so when we're talking about side effects
could you do a quick recap what is that
a side effect in shiny
side effect is there should be no
follow-up reactivity
so there's nothing else to calculate and
the side effect would be like printing a
message
right getting a file
right because if we print to the console
like there's nothing that's going to
happen after that
correct
look at that all of our buttons
whoops whoops
caught it made a mistake
there we go play again and game
excellent buttons are hooked up
cool
and
when we go through this app development
i would act personally i leave messages
until the very end
because if you may have hooked it up now
but it may get unhooked
due to something and so then it's just
nice to have
especially since this is a very
flowchart
workflow
yes so you're saying i could make
mistakes in my code and unhook my
buttons
yes let's do a little bit more about the
consequences
let's yeah let's fill in the the dragon
logic the cave logic let's actually make
this function outside of shiny okay
if i put something down here does shiny
ever see it like if i write a function
here is shiny gonna be like oh there's
that function or is this like scratch
paper
um
so it will uh because it is outside the
server function the server function is
only parsed it is not executed
immediately
it is only executed when the file is
returned the only thing that you uh need
to do
is 67 where it says shiny app
that needs to be returned from the file
so that needs to be the last thing
that's the only requirement okay so
actually the server function and the ui
definition above is all free form you
can do anything you want in any order as
long as 67 is the last thing that's
returned
okay so we're going to develop a
function
so
um i mean can we call it consequences or
are we going to get ourselves in trouble
with too much
things okay
so we'll set up our function and before
we do it we'll move 67 below our
flowchart comment
so that it's the last thing returned
great
like i didn't hear anything you just
said
consequences we are going to write a
function so the input the argument to
the function
is going to be
k is it k well it's
cave one or cave two
uh so we could say cave number
okay
there's i mean there's ways that we can
actually like
distill it down to a coin flip but um i
like the idea of cave
is this where we would set like friendly
dragon not friendly dragon
uh how would you define friendly dragon
and code is the thing so if we're doing
a coin toss eventually
friendly dragon the match or the not
match
i guess i would say like
well one it does it theoretically
doesn't matter right like we just have
to make a decision um i would want the
friendly dragon to be a match
right like he's going to be i like it
okay
that that idea goes really well because
if we had three caves you could have two
angry dragons and one
friendly dragon i'm
more thinking this of like a coin toss
at a basketball game or a football game
right
if you guess the toss
then or you guess the random value then
you win
um okay
and so you could have like a six-sided
die and if you guessed the side of the
die you found the friendly dragon or a
two-sided die
that right so would we just sample would
we just sample one or two
yes okay
i'm gonna
sample so sample is gonna be is it just
one to two size equals one replace
equals
fall
i guess it doesn't replace doesn't
actually matter
correct because because size is one yeah
and if uh that's always let's go ahead
and kill the shiny hat so that you can
like run 69 like
five six times
uh
oh there we go okay
buy a lottery ticket you got a lot of
is unexpected all right so we're going
to sample and then we want to assign
this to something
right
uh
yeah we could say friendly
okay
okay so basically i want if cave number
oh wait a minute
i want my cave number so that's whatever
button they've pressed
so we can imagine that's number one or
two
so would i just do cave number
equals friendly
and then if that's true what would you
do so i guess it would be something like
congratulations you have a new dragon
friend
right then
uh what if it's not friendly
so then it would be else
okay so that's i mean that's the basic
logic so if
the cave number equals whatever we've
said is it so if we have a match great
you've got a dragon friend
if not you've been eaten so this is
fairly straightforward but now we need
to hook up consequences
to our button press
right before we do that we test the
function just to see that it works
that's as we expect
all right so
the best way to test this
same idea but starting at 67. thank you
all right so then i could do like
friendly
one
nope that's not the name of the function
oh we got eaten all right
we've got a new dragon friend so
it's picking up yeah it looks like
perfect
it works
um okay so now we have consequences this
returns the the response text so that is
pretty cool
um
don't we uh can we scroll up to the ui
definition to see if the response text
is a text output i think you're wanting
that 428
yeah text output
we we could call this
consequence text maybe
okay so
output
id
um so then we can observe event in cave
one or two like we already doing and
what little pitfall are we about ready
to do
i'm not going to put i'm not putting a
reactive inside my observer
right
[Laughter]
i feel like that's a yeah
that's just an unfriendly dragon that's
like an unfriendly
dragon that will climb out of your
computer we do not put reactives inside
observers
or renders or renders but renders are
yeah yeah yeah randomness are
reactive issues
um
yeah so we don't do that um so
we still need to render text somewhere
so where do we do that
um
[Music]
well obviously it's outside the observer
so we can just start it then just
like
i like since it's near k1 k2 logic
cannot either play again let's just do
it like after 55
okay so in here
and this would be um
output and then this has to match
a really long name
it's descriptive
all right so output consequence text
and that could we just do
consequences function
uh
so if we did that um there would be no
reactive or reactivity
like you would not be able to click a
button because consequences would only
occur once
right
so we need a render text to pair with
the text
output okay so
then can it be render text consequences
uh
closer warmer
um so consequences since it's now inside
the render text great
um but we haven't given it like a cave
number
yes
so
i want the output of consequences text
and then i want it to print
the consequence i wanted to print either
friendly or not friendly response
based on cave number and cave number is
going to be whether
this button was pressed or this button
was pressed
this
so
if we were to write this in in normal r
code how would you not reactive code
would you
use a variable in between
yes
yeah i would say like
cave number
can i just put can i put that in here
where would where would i put my cave
number
uh let's let's go ahead and and put a
cave number in there in 57
and then um
we'll pretend that it's reactive and
we'll then create it
okay
okay
so we have our cave number there
um
right okay so then is it cave
[Music]
number
[Music]
is it reactive
reactive vowel or active value i like
reactive vowel
there might be a more elegant solution
by doing reactive or
um something else but i like the idea of
doing reactive vowel it's very explicit
and you have very fine-tuned control
okay so then my reactive valve is
i guess where i'm still stuck is like i
have two separate buttons and i don't
know how to put
which one was clicked inside
my reactive
so if we were to do this in a normal if
statement you would be like if
button was pressed
then
code and he would say like one is
cave number
and then else if
button two is pressed then
two is cave number so how do we assign
to a reactive vowel
value like how do we assign
a
is there like an update function
um
not yet um so let's let's go ahead and
go after line 50. okay because cave 1
was pressed in line 50 we know we're in
that situation
so then we'll say cave
under number parentheses one
wait what the heck is that
so that's how you can update a reactive
file you submit new number
what
so then this will be cave number two
yes
and did that is this just gonna work now
i hope so
um oh text out oh detect out put
listen first
i think t
argument is applying
zero correct
um
so this is actually a consequences
function
um
but
we we can probably skip the consequences
function because i like how it is it's
very independent of
leave it as is
but let's update our render text on line
60
okay
and this is also why like earlier we're
trying to move in very small steps
because
we have a thing of length zero and we
did like five different new things
so which one was it
um
yeah so inside the rendered text
the default actually what we can do in
59 let's do this one first 59 the
default value is null let's just pretend
that they always picked cage like cave
one
so let's say the reactive valve one
okay so we would just do that
yeah and then let's run the app and see
if that fixes our rx0 great
um
okay so
stuff is happening in the console
what is not happening there so let's go
check our function
okay yes so
we've got a message
right so our function prints out a
message so if we were running this
independent of shiny our message is
printing out to the console
we were doing this like in a standard r
script that is behaving as we would
expect
true but the function needs to return
the text not display the text so would
it can i just do return
uh you can do return since it's also the
last thing in the function you can just
take off the return parentheses
completely oh
and it'll take yeah perfect
easier it's easier if we reload
okay
great
and this is now kind of fun because the
consequences is random it's not like
okay one is always friendly if you
refresh the app three four times then
the consequences text should
change unless you're very lucky
there we go
okay so we got the consequences
text to ch come on there we go oh
there we go
we've changed it works
cool great
but we're still not hooked up to our
button
well oh that's okay okay yeah so that's
okay um
oh so you should be able to hit cave one
cave two and it should at least
you know it may be the same text but
yeah so it's not like actually reading
what i'm oh because i know because it's
recalculating each time we haven't like
linked it
each time
okay so each time i click this button it
is independently running sample
so at some point but you should only be
able to guess once
and so that's where like intro should
only be displayed then questions should
only be displayed you click the button
once then you go immediately to the
consequences you're not allowed to click
the button again got it okay so is this
where we so we've got kind of the logic
plugged in is this where we start so is
this now where we would like chop
everything up into four screens
sounds good to me
okay you sent me a slack message and my
response was the what
you had said okay so you had today is
going to be all about tab set panel type
equals in tab panel body with
transitions via observe event and update
tab set panel
if you actually want to pull up the help
for tab set panel
in that
quadrant there
perfect
and
so let's scroll down and look at the
examples
documentation
and what we're going to do is
this
second example uh the ui one in the
middle where we
have a tab panel body
oh down here
and
what this is so tab set panel is um you
normally have like something that you
can click on to change the different tab
sets
if you do type as hidden those things
that you can click on disappear
like the titles are gone
and yes little spooky but
the way you transition is using the
update tab set panel function
so it's programmatic so we know when the
button is clicked we automatically
change to the next thing
we know when
something happens we change the next
thing
okay so that's it's it's not spooky um
but we can
we can do this as a tab panel and then
transition to a tap panel bonnie body
once it works
okay so
i don't need to i'm not doing a sidebar
layout main panel but i would pick up
from like tab panel
yes so we can just tab panel tab set
panel there
oh tabs that panel sorry thank you
okay and then
all of this goes inside of it everything
well all of my follow the ui except for
40 yeah there we go
right so we are now inside of a tap set
panel and let's now
add in the id for the tab set panel
okay so
id is going to be
uh dragon tabs
yeah dragon tab yeah
okay
and
great then let's do
let's not do type is hidden maybe we
write it out and then comment it okay
great
and then let's do
all right so our first one is gonna be a
yeah so am i gonna put each chunk inside
tab panel body
um
let's do it as um
a tab panel first but yes um the
contents will be the second argument got
it second plus argument
like tab panel
and then this will be intro
yes i like short simple names here even
though they may not look pretty
feeling a little attacked but that's
fine
no no i like what you did um because if
there's spaces we can't update it
programmatically as easily
oh okay
all right i was gonna show off my one
cool trick all right intro
question and then i'm just kind of
the way that i'm doing this i'm just
leaving my headings in here i'm not
gonna worry about it too much
i'm gonna remember to move my commas
around
this is a tab panel
and this will be
consequences there are consequences when
you choose consequences as your
as your text because then you have to
type it
and then um
if you want you could actually put the
play again in the consequences
oh that's true that's true kind of
yeah no
do you want to play again
yeah that's fair i feel like that's
usually where it shows up oh
space
um
and i forgot these guys oh gosh all
right made a mess here we go
fixed it um
is that everyone
i think so i'm not getting any errors so
okay so i put everything in tab panel
if i run it
cool
yeah so let's switch to the question
switch to the consequences
one we would absolutely use this like in
a report right like we wouldn't
necessarily like continue
like but like
data science data analyst business
intelligence right like this is oh
here's some intro text or instructions
and here's that you know okay so this
this does relate to data science i
promise
all right all right so we've made panels
now
now what do we do
uh so the update method ups update tab
set panel
can be done
so it's programmatic updating and that
can be done with a regular tab panel
body or a regular tab panel or tab panel
body okay
required for tab panel body
so let's go ahead and try to do this
update tab set panel for all of our
output or observe events
okay so one thing that i'm noticing in
the help documentation
is update tab set panel is actually
happening in our server function so it's
not something we're applying into our ui
we're putting it into our server
function
correct so what i'm seeing is it's on
our server function we have observe
events we have lots of observers
um we've got a button pressed is would i
put update tab set panel around
all of my messages
uh just after i mean you can have many
lines of code in the observe events like
curly bracket section that's why we do a
curly bracket
um
so we'll we can just
paste it there like that
but we need to fill out the details of
where we're going to
and how we're getting there so
first argument
is it needs to be the session object
so we'll just do session comma because
you're providing that on 55.
okay so now my second argument says
hidden tabs
and that will match to the id of the of
the big tab set panel and we said that
was dragon tabs okay so
we are professionals
and then
selected what is
this
well what's the next argument i guess is
what i'm saying your destination where
would you like to go i would like to go
to
my cave
section so
i instead of intro i would like to go to
can i just put in question yes question
oh that's it so like
selected
equals question
yes
all right
let's see if the app works yeah that was
i was like we got to test this
baby steps
you are in a landfill of dragons
that's so cool
okay okay
so then
so 59 can now be copy pasted kind of in
a lot of different places
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
boom
yay and then your your console is freed
up like everything
is nice and neat look at that okay so
now you said what you had some other
things other tricks
so let's uh
turn this into hidden yeah so type
hidden
and
is that it um
uh we need to change tab panel body
so now let's have panel to tab panel
body whoa bode
i can't remember if i did a capital b
you know what we can do
we're going to come to our friend the
help documentation
tab
and a body yep
and
the signature for the function
technically changed
so for a tab panel the id defaults to
the title which the title is the first
argument
and i just had to
provide simple names that could be
interpreted as an id
but a tab panel body the first argument
is the id
so it switches a little bit but like
just because we use nice simple names
and we didn't do anything else it'll
work out it'll still work yeah we don't
have to change it
right because if i had done like
consequences of decisions that's very
hard to that would be really bad for
where we are
right now
okay
let's
do that so now i'm so excited i think i
know what's going to happen
so it took away our there's nothing so
now we can completely direct someone
oh my gosh
it works
i feel like okay i feel like part like
there's a lot of good things that we did
and we learned here
um i think
this to me is such an interesting like
obviously making games is a ton of fun i
will like
i learned so much just doing this but
then i'm thinking like use cases for
this like this is a really
if you want to like direct someone
through your app um this would be really
useful or you can like direct them and
give them choices
um that's really powerful
yeah force force the workflow um of your
application like
when you go to intro you can only go to
the question you cannot go to
consequences
you have to go to question question
this was so cool it was so
i don't want to say it was easy
because i still get stumped on
reactivity
but like i thought this would be the
hard part was um hiding the tabs and
like the conditional stuff but that was
that was ridiculous that was so easy
you can also imagine if you didn't have
the logic the transition logic and the
other things like if we hit everything
first
it's really hard to debug
like how do you know if your
consequences are working right now like
i don't know
yeah so just do the tap panels at the
end
lesson learned thank you for
not letting me go down the path i tried
to go
[Music]
you